هذه العمليه الاسرائيليه
اقتحمت من خلالها القوات الاسرائيليه
بعشرات الدوريات العسكريه مصحوبه بجرافه
عسكريه حيث حصلت المنزلين وطلبت واخلت
السكان من المنازل المجاوره ايضا وذلك
قبيله ناسفهما العمليه العسكريه في بلده
كفردان تخللها مواجهات مع شبان البلده حيث
اصفر ذلك عن همم حسب وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه عن استشهاد الشابين محمد حوشيه
وفؤاد عبد واصابه خمسه اخرين بجروح وصفت
الثاني منهم بالخطيره القوات الاسرائيليه
ايضا تعرضت لعمليات اطلاق نار من قبل
المقاومين فلسطينيين همم يتبعون لكتائب
شهداء الاقصى التابعه لحركه فتحه ايضا الى
كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس الذراع
المسلحه لحركه الجهاد
الاسلاميه الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه
استهدف هذين المنزلين
وقام بنسبهما بعد اتهامهما اتهام الجيش
الاسرائيلي للشابين عبد الرحمن واحمد عابد
بتنفيذ هجوم مسلح قرب حاجزي الجلمه
العسكري شمالي مدينه جنين والذي اسفر ذلك
الهجوم عن مقتل ضابط اسرائيلي هو المسؤول
عن وحده الاستطلاع والمراقبه في النقاط
التماس في شمالي مدينه جنين حركه حماس
والجهاد الاسلامي وايضا وزاره الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه دانه الجرائم الايصاليه
المستمر بهدم منازل الفلسطينيين وايضا
بقتل الفلسطينيين واكد اكدت هذه المؤسسات
وهذه تنظيمات والفصائل الفلسطينيه بان هذه
الجرائم واستمرارها همم بحق الفلسطينيين
الان ينال من صمود الشعب الفلسطيني ويصلون
على استمرار المقاومه في وجهها الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره جنين
فلسطين